greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by quip one of the most important
things we do for our health every day is
brushing our teeth yet most of us don't
do it properly quip is a better electric
toothbrush created by dentist and
designers quip was designed to make
brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and more enjoyable I'll tell
you why I love quip ok it gets to every
tooth it's tremendous it's a built-in
two-minute timer pulses every 30 seconds
to remind you when to switch sides
helping you guide a full and even clean
so why I love quip that's why I love
quip and that's why they backed over
twenty thousand dental professionals
that's why it's there backed by over
twenty thousand dental professionals
quip starts at twenty five hours and if
you go to get quick calm slash Joey
right now you'll get your first refill
pack for free free with quip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
for free I get quip dot-com slash Joey
again GE t qu IP dot-com slash Joey love
I love quip I'll tell you this you're
gonna love them too number two the
church is brought to you by my bookie
[ __ ] its
mid-season this is it you got baseball
playoffs today you got college football
you got pro football you got hoop
started a couple [ __ ] weeks this is
the money making part of the year and my
bookies there for your why you play you
win you get [ __ ] paid you
understand me listen you've been on the
sidelines for too long it's time to get
in the game why have the [ __ ] winner
if you can't [ __ ] depend on who you're
[ __ ] betting with that's what my
bookie comes in log in to my bookie
right now and double your money you like
Joey when he talk double McGee this
right now use promo code Church and
you'll get your first deposit matched at
a hundred percent
that's promo code Church you play you
win you get paid my bookie take that
[ __ ] melee my favorite I was telling
you that I still remember when this song
was on the radio when this
is November of 83 I like that you played
I don't think I've ever been here when
you've played a girl a female vocalist
oh I love all that I know love all this
stuff I like the song and I still
remember getting in a car it was cold I
had just come from Sarasota Florida I've
been hiding from the cops and I'm in
this car and I got a job at a factory
painting shelves and putting boxes
together cuz as the men's when you're
going through a supermarket yeah this
has a shelf those estimates show yeah
how would spray-paint them know what a
gun and then we put him in showers you'd
have to build them at the store so I got
a job if I stayed there for 30 days I've
become Union it was my first shot of
being a human being again how old were
you I was 19 oh wow
ferny my buddy had a his father had the
H&B diner around the corner
it was right next door a bount islands
were a lot of where they shot
Copland it should be dying that was the
heart of the city like people were it
was back everyday I don't think I knew
you lived in Florida no the same [ __ ]
Florida said Sarasota I was in Sarasota
hiding now from the cops
oh I come back when I find that the cops
were looking for me no more and I moved
my body ferny I love that you hid in
Sarasota by the way that's the only buy
had a friend that was a Sarasota yeah
because they was G Hartman not like
Alaska or Mexico just Florida well at
that time everybody from Jersey only was
to Florida right the only thing about
Jersey they were little in Atlantic City
is a big time of year when they break up
the white shoes and then the other side
they go to [ __ ] Florida Jersey goes
before I'd say isn't nothing west of the
Mississippi so I had a friend that his
father worked for NASA and they lived as
far they moved to Florida when he was a
sophomore and he came back my senior
year all [ __ ] jumped up like [ __ ]
tan yes Jack you ever want to come down
I'm dying that dying is lonely this man
he would have taken anybody really and I
remember going I have the cops are
looking for me on a Sunday night and I'm
gonna [ __ ] I called him up I had his
number go Gary I'm coming down
I didn't tell him the cops are looking
for anything no you don't usually leave
like that happening I'll pick you up he
was so [ __ ] excited just to have
somebody he was so lonely just to have
somebody that knew what he was about
yeah how crazy he was [ __ ] how much time
of your life would you say you spent
hiding from the law hiding from the law
and from people altogether maybe three
years what if he combined everything
that's amazing so those are those first
two months but I always had something
bad going on Kate like there was always
something in the pipe like criminal or
just personal personal I always had
something in the pike I was working on
mmm Kate came over here with a bag of
coke and she made me drop her off in
front of the dealers house so now I knew
it there was a dealer that huh right so
I would walk over there one night then
I'd find out what his name was
so I always had something working I
always had somebody looking for me yeah
you always had a you know if I if I got
to the point in my life that if I wasn't
in trouble I wasn't happy huh like I
live in a place if that if I wasn't in
trouble I wasn't happy I had to go to
sleep every night scared for me to go to
sleep from the pain I was going through
my mother and having no family I got to
a point that I didn't care about life
and I would just be people I've been
there I been there like where you give
up or you just almost like when you're
in pain
you want to do reckless [ __ ] because
somehow like the more reckless you the
world was mean to you so now you're
gonna be mean back to the world yeah the
world was a scumbag to you and this is
the first time you've that the world has
been a scumbag to you so your immediate
reaction of my reaction as a young man
was to lash out against the world
regardless of who I hurt and I kept a
circle of people that I didn't try to
involve him but they would always get
involved because they would always hear
about it so if every Luke 8 was my
Goomba
with him I did something Kate would have
to hear about yeah of course [ __ ]
buddy is up to it again
yeah and you know I listened his mother
died you know give him a breather [ __ ]
that he robbed my friend's house and
then he's out there doing coke and he
told to go [ __ ] himself and you know so
my friends are always getting the blunt
of that and that's why today I'm really
good to those people all those times I
would disappear they'd be in the barn
they take the blunt of it he would come
to go his cocoa what what are you
talking about yeah he robbed my house
last night and we know it's him and
[ __ ] we're gonna [ __ ] him up and my
friends would giggle what would your
they would they would they would love it
they would love it that's inside be
scared they would love it no way just
two three days ago sometimes like I said
I go to the coffee shop - right yeah hey
I may end up writing something else is
an exercise yeah you told me you just
write you don't even think about it
right I wrote a story that was really
funny to me
I met this cat when I was a freshman in
high school but I really don't want to
say his name you know I'm not friends I
haven't spoken to him in 30 years but I
met this cat he was a rich kid his
father was a mobster left his mother for
a younger girl typical [ __ ] yeah and his
father just play candidate by throwing
money out and you know he had a z28
he always had new cars he always had new
stereos his mother got [ __ ] fat and
ugly and his he had his hat aunt that
was a half a mo mo she had had like of
her nervous breakdown and she didn't go
to work or some [ __ ]
no ma yo if you just set the kitchen and
what game shows all day with my [ __ ]
teeth so I became friends with him
through other friends and one of the
guys that adopted me if my crummy living
Maibaum one night when they tried to be
a tough guy with Mike and that's the one
got to be a tough guy away and might lit
him up at the park on 51st Street park
bloodied his face yeah that was he broke
his nose yeah it was blood everywhere so
he always knew I was Mike's Goomba
so he was always kind of standoffish
with me him as I am yeah I might see him
he'd say hello he was courteous but you
know I was Mike's brother and you can't
tell me a story about Mike of course you
can't come to me
yeah anything about my cos I'll smack
you I have friends like that
so me and it became kind of friends and
we would take rides and they were all
scared to go into the city
they were reefer heads so I would say
I'll take you to the spot my fee was a
bag to drive them they would drive oh
and I would get out of the car walk into
the spot get the briefing and get back
in the clown give it to them
little did they know I would take a butt
out of their bag I was working with
today yeah and I knew the guys in the
bodega they would take care of me ba ba
ba so you know I kind of liked them but
he still wasn't one of my favorites and
one night when I was like a junior or
the beginning of my senior year I saw
him out one night and he goes get in the
car you want to take a ride with us and
was smoking pot listen to loud music
going around North Bergen where I live
and he had a crush on this girl and the
girls are hanging out in front of this
park and it was four of us and he got
out of the car started talking to the
girl well guess what the girl had a
boyfriend that was a [ __ ] gorilla he
rolled up with one of his buddies and
without provocation she started beating
up on my buddy yeah just try that just
opened up so all that's three get out of
the car and I'm trying to de-escalate
the situation how by just breaking them
apart the guy he was rough they they
called him Rocky
like his fall on the diner in Fairview
New Jersey or some [ __ ] and the guy was
a big kid he was roided-up he [ __ ]
pummeled Perry that was the kid's name
so we all got back in the z/28 he
dropped us off about a week later
somebody's had their dog you know he's
manager but he said you didn't have his
back what are you talking about it was
four against two
we would have killed those guys there
was no reason to escalate the situation
yeah they would just come back with
twenty guys and then a whole town was
that war yeah let's just break it up
yeah nobody take that punches and that's
what I told him he goes well he took it
like whatever so I confront another body
as well I wanted to find him I go parrot
he was knocking the [ __ ] out here you
weren't going nowhere here there was
nowhere to go so over the years and when
have had this thing we were cool because
we had mutual friends Cerreta we ended
up a difference in different places I
leave I go to Colorado I never think
about him I move on with my life
I go back to New Jersey in 84
everybody's a drug dealer everybody's in
the Mafia everybody's selling coke
everybody it's like leaving right now
and coming back and weed when I come
back lien you a big time we coke dealers
I'm like oh it's so weird though like
how come no one discovered that's how
cocaine spread the early eighties it was
that fast
damn 83 to 85 it's spread like a [ __ ]
wildfire
when you watch the 75 or the documentary
they're not lying it took over like it
was where they were selling you would be
coming here for years to this corner to
buy weed and one day you shut up and
they're like hey no more weed no more
there's a straight-up rock of this
[ __ ] yelling that's how he had
taken over huh
so when I moved back I bumped into one
day he's like talking about this coke
nobody else has this can actually gave
me two blasts cane it was out of this
[ __ ] world
what did you like the first time I tried
coke I was already I was 16 but that's
insane now I'm 21 22 21 and I moved back
to North Bergen for some stupid reason
and I bump into him he's telling me that
he's selling coke his father owned the
construction company so he worked
construction he was always a big giant
construction he was a degenerate gambler
soda to placate this chick he had stolen
that check for that dude no but she was
like a high money chick yeah you have
lift the rock if he wanted that [ __ ]
that's why she was dating a dude who his
father owns a deli she was one of those
girls she was yes that's the high money
yeah that's where the money is good
seeing a day most if so he got to come
up with Jesus to date this girl you know
and he had the construction job he
gambled and then he told me when they
got the coke business so I'm I see
system in you just way some customs in
my way
I'll take care from time to time
Christ's mother helping him out it was
easy in those days everybody was looking
for Coke every yeah every day you woke
up like that gram 1/4 ounce they were
leaving to my amp somewhere for a month
they wanted to take it with them there
was always a way to make money in those
days so one night I saw him we was we
were working together for like three
weeks we send them people over there or
me picking it up from him and and we had
worked out about percentage yeah like
like five points a week
give me like [ __ ] hundred cash maybe
I'll tell you what give me a gram of
coke because it's a hundred to me but
it's sixty five cost to you yeah he's
like no I'm cutting the percentage yeah
I was like you just made a bad mistake
like in the back of my mind my [ __ ] with
the wrong yeah I know you got robbed
yeah like I already knew it was in the
robber that's holy he was just on a hook
I would just put people on Hulk give him
time to forget about what happened yep
whatever altercation happen between us
I'd give a six months and one day when
the timing was right I clip you bang
yeah when I'd even learn your delivery
schedule that's insane like I knew you
were getting the from if I would drive
by and see his car in front of you ass
you just picked up that means it's in
your house that means if I go to a bar
tonight and you're at the bar drinking
with your friends there's nobody at the
house you're just like that means I got
an hour to get down to the house take
the [ __ ] down I would just check your
door it no there's no [ __ ] thievery
well it's not like they're gonna call
the cops at all those missing what are
you gonna say no no no that's what I
knew and then they would come to me but
they would have sufficient proof yeah
and I had six gorillas that I grew up
with that wouldn't let something like
that happen to me saying I'm saying like
they wouldn't let this go down so they
was forgotten about people would just
move on and go that [ __ ] robbed
me did you ever do that and regret it
did anything bad ever come out of it
yeah I got a reputation and then
everything that happened he's got points
for that me alright then everybody
thought you did a door
once I read that anytime somebody got
robbed it was me and then what happened
was I got accused of doing something I
really didn't do and it destroyed me
what was it because they were close
friends of mine a friend of mine said I
robbed his house I wasn't leaving living
in that area at the time oh so I had to
call the Chief of Police who I knew
personally I'm out with his son I know
these people these political people
accusing me robbing a house I live up in
Cresskill I'll even come into that area
cuz I had people looking for me
not very canary Hadley three drug
dealers people looking for you
everywhere this was crazy that's how I
lived I would beat two or three or four
people for ten thousand piece eight
thousand six thousand and I would lock
myself up an old towel for [ __ ] a
month these foods blow in that area and
I'd wait for it to cool down then I come
back like nothing happened that's so
crazy nothing would happen I've never
broken into someone's house well I like
to get revenge but only for personal
like if someone hurts me personally like
emotionally I'll get [ __ ] revenge and
do crazy at that time like you said I
was in pain right and everything that
happened it was the world doing it to me
so I would have to rob yeah that was my
way of lashing out at the world was my
robbing people yeah and sometimes I just
feel like I want to make someone like if
someone hurts me I'm like ah I want to
make them feel it like I want to teach
them a lesson but I want to do it in a
way that they'll like never know it was
me
but they'll feel what I felt and then I
get revenge on people and then I always
regret it my friend Sarah says before
you seek revenge dig two graves one for
you one for them every time I've gotten
revenge like within a month I regret it
really bad the last person I got revenge
on actually the last person I got
revenge on you were with me well you
weren't with me when I got the revenge
but you were with me when I was talking
to this dude and he hurt my feelings and
he blocked my number and I was upset and
he said some mean [ __ ] to me and then I
came back to LA now I can say this
because there's no police report but I
came back to LA and one night I got
drunk and I
on a cape a Supergirl cape and a
fuck-boy patrol hat and I went to his
house with my girlfriend and my gay
friend in the middle of the night and I
hopped a fence and then I got inside and
I sat on the ground and I had no plan
like I came for revenge but I didn't
know what I wanted to do then I started
pulling pieces of paper and markers out
of my purse and I made a bunch of signs
that said crazy [ __ ] like seeking hot
guy who will [ __ ] me has to text me back
if you know someone please give him this
number I wrote a number on the sign then
I drew a picture of me with like huge
boobs like I drew like a caricature of
what I look like and said this girl is
DTF no drama
this sign has been glued to your door
with [ __ ] juice and I taped all these
signs to this guy's door in the middle
of the night like 3 o'clock in the
morning with the inside of the house
well on the outside of his door it's an
apartment complex actually get this out
of the way this is not revenge this is
an act of alcoholism know why I was I
wasn't you were mad at me you're a
little mad I wasn't mad at you I was
just it was revenge disappointing
because you're on a different level in
your life I shouldn't be dealing with
that that's just I if he [ __ ] hurt
you directly I could see he didn't do
one he did everyone haven't been going
back in this stupid game for ten [ __ ]
five years so you know that's not
revenge
I never there was one girl I thought it
was because she called the cops on me
something like that I seek revenge but
that type of stuff you will end up in
trouble you will dig two graves for
yourself but it was revenge this is a
small community was it was revenge for
some he had said to us and says I'm back
don't know the jump is fence at the
[ __ ] juice on his door what wasn't real
[ __ ] juice video of you [ __ ] with you
talking that was just a little out of
all talking you didn't think that was
funny not even by a [ __ ] third the
apology video the talking vagina even at
any level wait Ilia exactly am I even
had a conversation will tell you we were
both like I wanna hear
oh yeah we were both like what are you
thinking wait a minute if you got in a
fight with your girlfriend me and this
guy were like that was just out of
[ __ ] bounds
the [ __ ] video or the hopping the fence
the whole thing
I think the [ __ ] video is hilarious
people don't yes he is not even your
boyfriend
no he is not even your boyfriend but he
was mad at me so I sent him okay listen
the people don't know I sent him a
talking vagina apology I said I'm sorry
I made you mad and I made my vagina talk
and I said don't be mad at Kate be mad
at this [ __ ] you can even beat it up
that was way over that's funny you been
with this guy messing around with him
playing that game for five you know you
get what you deserve
I had games people really don't know you
know you really gotta know the end where
you're dealing with a relationship in
life and sometimes you gotta learn when
the [ __ ] back the [ __ ] off yeah but
wait you yeah I keep I am the I am the
most vengeful person in the world he
blocked me and so yes nothing wrong with
your [ __ ] life but you don't want to
be bothered but not for you to jump his
fence listen to what you did at 3:00 in
the morning we have plans the cops go
pee what if the counselor showed up that
would have been amazing I would have got
a mug shot you know what no no what not
done today's [ __ ] society in today's
environment foot some guy if I can smash
you will grabs your [ __ ] and you stab
them I'm driving you
yeah I'm saying yeah some guy gets out
of control with you I'll Drive you and
give you the weapon and get rid of the
weapon and burn the Gunpowder off your
hands I'll help you thank you because
I'm that type of person I know what is
worse I know what it feels it's like a
dear friend once told me if you come to
me and tell me the truth and don't miss
a detail I'll do anything in the world
for you me too
so but when you pick those bounds that
that was just dumb from A to Z that was
the worst thing yeah Tyrone the
but here's the thing cuz you get crazy I
see you get crazy those out of all
things
I hardly ever take at all you'll get
crazy and they stock up in your body and
I could tell when you're tweeting and
your honor that [ __ ] no good yeah
that's how good I am in it I just told
my listen I am an addicted sack of [ __ ]
I have done every drug there is so
there's one thing about me
you cannot come at me any other way I
got bottom we have a mutual friend about
three months ago I looked at him and I
go that guy is doing well Italy was like
no no I know what you're talking about
trust me I'm telling you I've been there
I know the characteristics I know the
characteristics yeah I know
I build it every I've been hooked on
vicodin have enough valium I've been on
coke you know I never got a dependency
the heroin cousin ever did it
back-to-back nights I always waited a
week but I know the steps of a junkie I
am a junkie that's why I was depressed
with you because the drugs had something
this is something Kate the comic would
have not done and this is why you have
to check every level of what you do
especially in today's environment you
know what for me when someone blocks me
and I know it's my abandonment issues
and I know it's my own [ __ ] I need to
like work on but when someone blocks me
like I would you know I would rather
guide punch ah especially if I didn't
the thing is with that dude and I know
what you're saying it was immature but
that guy literally like does it for fun
and I couldn't take it anymore I just
snapped that's what we do I mean but he
doesn't even have a reason he'll go I
love you block man that block you you
know why he blocked me because I said
that he went down on me while I was on
my period meant he was in love with me
and he got mad sure he wants to hear
that we're adults here
nobody wants to hear it or tweet it when
it's about them and you that type of guy
I didn't tweet it I've set it on a pot
yeah so what do you expect 20 whoo it
didn't matter he [ __ ] heard it he's
be the first one listen to your podcast
you know it's just it's a compliment
listen how do you get how do you get in
some of these pants me you really want
somebody I need to get in some of these
pants anybody
well how you getting some of these pants
when you really want you leave Omaha or
reject them on the wall nobody could
figure it out when you're loud on
somebody for two months and one night
you like I'm done with this [ __ ] you go
to a strip club and you bother the same
[ __ ] every day for two months
she's Manning tells you she's got a
boyfriend or whatever and then you go
and then you pull out the baddest [ __ ]
for 800 or 1,000 bucks whatever she
wants you come back that strippers gonna
be pissed off at you
it's just something about women and men
that drives is crazy shutdown comics
have the same I used to study comics at
the store when a comic is big-time and
he's holding court he's not concerned
about the six people that I hold in
court he's concerned about the one guy
standing in the corner not listening
always okay he's not pissed off about
the seven people he's not concerned
about them he's got them
yeah I've seen stars go up to the store
I was been sitting in a lot you smoking
pot watching and I would watch the
so-called stars you know holding court
but a certain comics not even giving a
[ __ ] that they were there you could see
it was driving them crazy it's human
nature it's a [ __ ] I want the one
that's not paying attention I used I do
this sometimes like I was at a party one
night and there was a guy was into and
all the girls were kind of into this guy
like everybody was trying with them and
I talked to him for a few minutes and
then I just went in an empty room at
this party and I sat down on a couch and
I just started watching TV like I
literally just did my thing I come over
to you 15 minutes later he came in the
room hung out with me the rest of the
night and it was just cuz I was the one
that wasn't trying that's it that's it
yeah I felt like I won yesterday how
my reaction is to woman this is why ever
if something come up it's [ __ ]
because I need to break your balls like
I've had happened and Boulder 110 I was
on a date and I had met this girl you
know it wasn't it wasn't like a loud
white thing I knew her then we wanted to
either something and I didn't know I
give to see that movie blind date an old
movie from 87 it's hilarious Boosh
Willis Kim Basinger nice Kim bastard you
really didn't know what she wanted to do
she was making all these movies yeah
what these good-looking leading men and
she did this movie with Bruce Willis and
they told him specifically not to give
her booze to give her a booze there was
some people you cannot give booster and
before I took this girl out with my
demented mind her friend pulled me aside
I know whatever you do my demented male
like oh yeah that's the first I don't
know way yeah so the first place I took
it was for a shot and once she had the
first shot she lost it and she started
having more shots and getting louder and
then I'm like what am I gonna do with
this girl so I figured let me take it
back to the bar where her girlfriends
work so she could calm down now by no
means I do not want anybody to get me
wrong I wanted to [ __ ] this girl more
anything in the world she was beautiful
yeah I can't even believe she was on a
date with me I was just trying to do
comedy and she had a beautiful ensemble
and we would pulled up at the parking
lot she's gone crazy in the car like
singing loud like we would I have a
couple weeks ago a girl came a little
ease I was talking about how you asking
all this [ __ ] and he leave almost down
by one one cuz we can't have I can't
handle that [ __ ] either
yeah I don't drink so a drunk woman gets
on my last jumpy there's two types of
drugs woman is drunk women that are a
pain in the ass and this drunk will be
that have fun yeah she this at least
this girl was fine was fine yes making
me laugh but as we pulled up she turned
around looked at me
and she goes this is a perfect place for
us to [ __ ] this she trippin shirt and
she's just ripped her clothes off that
was her freak
she liked when you ripped her clothes
off yeah well who does she ripped her
clothes in the car in the car ripped her
skirt off and here we are in the parking
lot banging and I'm like out of water
like she [ __ ] this shoe I'm in the car
I gotta walk into this bar like we're
pissing out my breath and [ __ ] no man
they're like where is whatever her name
was and I'm like she's in the car I
couldn't tell her she couldn't come in
because she knew her rip was shredded
all her clothes are gone close the show
she was sitting in the car like a blank
oven waiting for me to bring him like a
[ __ ] vodka tonic holy [ __ ] for this
[ __ ] in the car we went back to my
place I gave her like sweatpants and a
shirt now she was adopted and her real
brother was visiting her from out of
town and her brother knew about the type
of freak she was hello when I dropped
her off she had her clothes when I
dropped her off she had to close there
and than a bundle with her heels like
she had ripped off her top wait what did
you give her to wear a shirt or
something okay well I took him back to
my house and gave him like sweatpants
she was tiny
she was a tiny chick yeah so like flying
chick I don't like fine clothes one of
the chicks like that I had you know over
the years yeah but you keep like a pair
of panties yeah so I dressed her up and
I had betaken her home and I'll never
forget like her like she was in like she
loved it that I attacked her and that
she ripped her clothes off she kept time
he ripped my skirt I was like I can't
you know and then she would then we
would kept date and she would Tommy
ripped my clothes look just don't rip
the Broncos there $40 she would have
like dollar store panties and I would
have to rip them off
oh my god so but I don't even though the
point we're getting to hit when she
first told me when she turned to Reese
cave and said so are we gonna [ __ ] Jayde
every piece of energy left my body like
I was ready if I could have I would have
pressed a button you know the early
James Bond car you'd shoot
like I will is shot out of the car yeah
because I'm the type of guy I have to
tell you okay you're looking good let's
see what that [ __ ] tastes like if you
bring it upon me there's guys that fold
huh have you ever been a guy were you
aggressive with him and he kind of fold
a little bit behind yes kinda I'm one of
those [ __ ] things I'll fold on the
prepping questioning it's happened to me
before where I'll go out with a guy okay
this drives me insane if you want to get
a girl to [ __ ] you here is a great way
to do it it's happened to me a couple of
times that I'll go on a couple dates
with a guy and I'll be into him but I'll
hold back I'm [ __ ] him because I
don't want to do it too soon because I I
like him right or I'm trying to set some
president like oh I want to actually
date him and a couple of times if I
don't [ __ ] him I like date three or four
they kind of disappear and if I like
them then I start to try to use the sex
to lure him back in I haven't done this
in a while but there's one guy in
particular I literally the last night we
hung out we were like almost hooked up
but we didn't and I was like next time
for sure we're [ __ ] and then the guy
never took me out again and I would text
him every once in a while like I would
send him a hot photo I'd be like I'm in
your neighborhood
let's get Nick I eventually just went
straight to let's [ __ ] like I was just
throwing it out there cuz I was once
someone won't sleep with me but I've had
it taste I want it I want it I can't
help it especially what they pull back
yes especially they go you know what I'm
gonna pass on tape yeah
cuz I'm like why what happened and then
it makes me go a little nutty cuz I'm
like trying to figure out why doesn't he
want to [ __ ] me and then of course like
the arrogant part of my brain is like
he's gay like that's my first go-to Mike
he's got to be gay why won't he [ __ ] me
or he has a girlfriend but it's happened
to me three or four times if I don't
[ __ ] them by date 3 or 4 they don't try
and then once I yeah once you throw it
out there you send a naked photo you try
too hard
they're out they're out some guys cannot
be and while guys listen to this come on
yeah Joe you don't know what you're
talking I'm telling you I've had friends
that have told me the same situations I
had a friend that
I have a dear friend that I still talk
to and when we were kids I was living in
Colorado went home and one night he goes
I want you to meet me at this bar when I
meet my new girlfriend and her name was
Karen but after years we started calling
her crazy Karen she was the real deal
yep and this was like maybe their fourth
date or their fifth date
and he got up to go to the bathroom and
she looked me straight in the face and
she goes so what I gotta do to get your
friends to [ __ ] me and I was I gonna bar
I was 21 I didn't know how to react what
are you talking about she goes I've done
everything I can for your friend the
[ __ ] is he gay he was gay lover like
that and she was New Jersey she was like
you a [ __ ] is he a [ __ ] with you he
walked back right into the conversation
and he goes what's going on no we just
talking he was no talent what's the deal
you ever gonna [ __ ] me and he [ __ ]
turned bail and he was like what type of
[ __ ] woman are you like I was in
shocked and then they in the babe for
years and yeah but after that she was
crazy Karen so it worked that scene but
like that's my like dream like I was
always like when you said that like girl
would you like someone the way to get
them is to not pay attention to them I
didn't get that memo like yeah you have
to figure it out I and I did yeah but
it's no it's true
I've been single home like ten months
and when I don't return a call or if I
like have to cancel cuz I have a podcast
or I'd rather do to this open mic they
they call it like they're all they want
to do is come over and I was nice for 28
years 29 years and it got me nowhere and
like it's so that and that that annoyed
me but then it also I would love like
it's crazy that you don't like when
girls are aggressive I think that's what
I need
no I would love that all you need to
grow smack you know I want to see hate
me but I love smack in the face like one
day sometimes I feel like a pervert cuz
guys guy you always have to be the one
to initiate you do not well but once the
girl in my house I don't know I like the
guy that kind of like
manhandled me a little but every once in
a while it's fun to dominate a guy
everyone on that hominid but just like
you shouldn't you need to get done
every once in a while you take the smack
you open hand in the face like a bee did
to Conor McGregor in the third round
just bitch-slap you and call you a
[ __ ] eat my [ __ ] you little [ __ ]
[ __ ] throw you down just sit on your
face but you back hands you were like a
glove he's my [ __ ] you're anti-semitic
and all this [ __ ] you Whateley do you
eat ass no no not a chance
why was poop up there you don't like to
stick your tongue all the way up it you
don't even like a leak around it there's
another there's some plenty of other
things to do as I've tried together no I
don't that's what brings them back their
[ __ ] and I don't care how many showers
you take out a little you eat you have a
story about taking tinfoil woman's
butthole did I die no I'm still [ __ ]
here that's I know but I don't over you
look at [ __ ] you feel a little piece
of [ __ ] on your tongue no no no no big
deal oh yeah you've been go look up the
rate of a fast-food burger remember when
they did that movie years ago about yes
forever that they had 90 fresh Holabird
girls frozen burgers at McDonald's they
didn't say McDonald's it was called
supersize me supersize yep and they said
that every hamburger they found fecal
matter everywhere in the source there's
probably some on this co-op I don't want
to get fecal matter from the phone but
if I'm gonna get fecal matter I'm gonna
get it from the girls I'm an [ __ ] I'm
getting it right from the source my
thing is if you like I like guys that
like love to devour women do it that's
why you always be single no I don't
wanna deal of with Paula cuz you didn't
have to have sex you were no I liked
having sex once a week she wouldn't suck
your dick in the morning
she wouldn't suck a dick at night she
wouldn't suck your dick when you were
dry you know you like that because
you don't want to be you have to be free
with a womanly [ __ ] you have to you
that it's just we really like if you
love somebody a little fecal matter in
your tongue a little piece of [ __ ] you
spit it out like a watermelon see you're
gonna watermelon in your mouth and you
keep eating that [ __ ] [ __ ] like
it's a [ __ ] like a cupcake I mean I
understand not wanting [ __ ] on it
because you Lena please your partner not
in that way oh my god you don't know
what it's like that for two fingers in
their [ __ ] from behind never gently at
the same time lick a little [ __ ]
licking machine gun that tongue and
they'll struggle oh oh and you just stop
drinking I'm [ __ ] harder and then you
put three fingers and then you start
switching it like a washer and dryer
tell me Kate Quigley that [ __ ] you
put three fingers out and you spin cycle
then you spread it out you do like the
three you give like a three single like
a and you eat that ass the whole time
and then moaning and groaning and then
there no I'm saying you feel a different
type of a grease coming out of their
[ __ ] it's like a grease it's like a
different type of gear juice and it's
making noises oh oh and you're [ __ ]
you grab and then you press the clip
with your thumb like a [ __ ] Savage
you [ __ ] turn it around and your
whole hand is spinning they're going
crazy yeah but you don't need to look
the [ __ ] a lick the [ __ ] you do
the spinner and then you take their leg
and you [ __ ] spin them violently and
you pick up the one leg and you put it
right here in your shoulder and you just
stick your dick you have two choices
right the fresh in their [ __ ] because
it's nice and I moved up from your
tongue just stick it in there without
just had my tongue in your ass that's
two that's a hint tongue no that's very
different from a dick well no no no I'm
going with the tongue and then before I
switch up in the tongue I'm gonna take
my finger from up here and stick it in
the [ __ ] and if I could push it all
the way back feel connected smaller than
your dick my finger is a lots of yeah
but that's why I'm priming it
what I'm doing is I'm fake I'm putting
the maluca thing in your [ __ ]
I want my index finger to meet my pink
look your fingers of Ronnie James Dio
does like this so if I could put my
finger my big thing in you [ __ ] and
get my pink in your [ __ ] right and
touch them together deep and now let me
explain something to you when you have
your finger in there [ __ ] that deep
the cave of death opens up which one's
the cave of death the cave of death is
the ass okay once you're became of death
open in the room in your finger then
you've got spitting your finger it does
smell you could smell these that could
be you can smell deep in the kidney but
you don't give a [ __ ] because you're in
love you're pleasuring your partner she
knows so right there the [ __ ] is 3/4
open plus its lubed with saliva the best
Lube there is you flip them over and you
keep that one leg by your ear you hook
the [ __ ] arm in you hook it in so the
leg can't go nowhere and you got two
ways to put your [ __ ] [ __ ] culture in
their little muffler while they play
with that [ __ ] in front here which Kate
loves you put it in their ass and they
start playing with that monkey and you
just pound on their [ __ ] [ __ ] and
you put you reach over and grab the far
shoulder to get them oh yeah this is
what [ __ ] animals like Kate what you
have to do I mean I I stopped letting
guys put their dick in my ass after you
told me they wouldn't take me to dinner
anymore I ask you this if a guy puts his
dude like we're doing coke with coked-up
I gotta [ __ ] or viagra me the cocaine
to kick the game time so I'm banging
Kate and she's playing with Homa Luke
stick himself right that now I can't mix
dicks and [ __ ] no you can't mix now I
gotta pull it out and coming to mouth
directly while she's playing with a
[ __ ] that's the party so you want to
suck a dick in that [ __ ] on she don't
give a [ __ ] she's a savage do you think
she's concerned about fecal matter I
would really just got [ __ ] the back
her insides feel it's like [ __ ] they
threw a bomb like the Koreans shot a
missile in the movie
that's what it feels like right now
she's sucking that dick like this
together oxygen back no no no common is
watch he swallowed I don't want no
matter in my mouth you're already in
your eye like a finger in there while
you [ __ ] me maybe like you know I'm cool
with that
my finger and when you get the finger up
their ass you know what the closure is
let the closer yeah you hook it what you
hook the [ __ ] with the finger you
don't leave it in there straight I have
to hook that's why I call it baby
hooking to what I was cool
I pull you towards me from your [ __ ]
from in your [ __ ] I pull you to I
trim my fingernails so I pull you deep
end so it doesn't scrape the inside of
the [ __ ] it's like that hook is the
whole thing the finger in the ass is
nothing it's when you curl your fingers
and you scrape your your your two cats
[ __ ] and the cat the mama Catholic
that's because he's scraping that a
helmet in that to get your cat's paw no
no no you hear without some Israel
there's hundreds of stray cats oh you
hear it every night it's terrible
I haven't been to Israel that's not what
I think finish playing with that [ __ ]
you mysteriously I get your hands to
their face so they could smell their own
[ __ ] doesn't seem like they do here's
what I have to say you loved this is the
mindset you have to have be a savage I'm
very careful to be cents ready to the
point where like if I [ __ ] during the
day I'm not kidding if I [ __ ] during the
day I will like get back in the shower
and make sure everything is clean in
case I hook up but and I will even like
go so far as to like clean up my
butthole
not for anal cuz I'm not doing that
until I'm like in love but for old
fingers do you look [ __ ] um
a guy wants me to I will but I will say
I will make sure he's had a shower I'm
not gonna guys [ __ ] [ __ ] that no no no
no you go in the shower that's why I'm
saying to you shower yeah like if I'm if
I expect a girl to suck my balls my
balls are in bad shape so I gotta give
him all the attention they can I go on
the shower I dry him off nice you like a
specific soap I can tense out this
creamy I then use like a loofah the
loofah your balls a little cut out from
my [ __ ] because that humus delivers
around your [ __ ] humus would you like
somebody's [ __ ] they don't they could
wipe all you want but water around it
yeah but barnacles from the [ __ ] will
clean that's it
so you have to get those barnacles out
that's why I get the loofah and I stick
like a quarter inch on finger the
barnacles I don't even trust her ass I
clean my ass with with summer's eve
everything I've heard it tastes like
skittles the girls that [ __ ] the most
clean they're [ __ ] the most one guy a
month the one boyfriend that they have
filthy [ __ ] disgusting snatches I
have [ __ ] chick that a [ __ ] a
different guy every weekend that [ __ ]
have been marvelous because they know
it's apparatus think I keep it clean
it's a chick you start date they eat
their ass in the morning and it smells
funky because they take you for granted
I'm not I'm actually kind of the
opposite because you know that I don't
have sex that much like oh you never but
but like because I am really horny I'm
always ready so if the opportunity
presents itself I don't want to have to
say no because I know that I like took a
[ __ ] and didn't take a shower so I'm
just always ready you know I've gone I
went to a girl's house after a spot and
I took a shower there I was like that's
okay than that I've been out of the
house what in the entire show I would
appreciate that yeah I recently hooked
up with a guy this is a new one for me I
hooked up with a guy and it was just
okay but I knew we had potential for it
to be amazing but I think he was just a
little too drunk so he wasn't like as
hard as he
could've been and then we ended up not
hanging out again and it's been really
bothering me because the first time in
my life a guy ever [ __ ] me and did
like didn't hit me up to do it again
and now it's like I'm on a mission to
[ __ ] him again because I need like I
have to like prove that it can be better
like I feel like it was mediocre well
it's like when you take that girl out
the first time and you don't expect to
have sex that's funny because I wrote a
joke about that years ago about a
particular girl that I saved money for
to take her out and I was gonna be the
perfect gentleman but the first night
turned into a [ __ ] fest Ginelli but on
the way home I forgot to lick her
[ __ ] like on the way home I was like
[ __ ] so rude of you that's how rude I
didn't flip her over
I didn't lick her a so I didn't come in
the mouth I had there was so many things
I had it done this is this one 22:23 I
was a [ __ ] animal I had no manners in
fact this is in Colorado and I called
the girl backup and we went to a movie
like after you [ __ ] somebody like this
to party is a young man you really want
to be real man they can do something
with them but at the end of time you
want to take a little um and [ __ ] him to
show him what you can really do like you
bring notes this time I eat her ass like
no this time choker I can look at cell
lists and I'm ever going out with her
and I like stuck my foot in my mouth it
was like dinner and a movie
and it was one of those movies that just
would not end you're dying
the whole time I'm fantasizing money in
a [ __ ] and sucking at Tennyson and
eventually I went over there but it was
humiliating four hours of [ __ ]
nonsense for me like you forget you
forget like you were so hot in the
moment that you forgot that looking a
[ __ ] of the lion or [ __ ] like that
so it would force me to call him back
that's how crazy I was at that age that
particular age yeah I was that crazy but
I learned something when I was really
young I was in love with a girl I was
brutally honestly in love with this girl
my mother had died something had
happened and I thought this girl would
save my life
you're gonna love with somebody you
think think of a save your wife like
that's how I how much in love I was with
this girl and I played this stupid game
of that you know and I played this
stupid phone game with her and I know
the girl want a dick like I knew it I'm
not the dog I'm not that crazy but the
girl held me up she held me up and then
she made a bad mistake one day were
having conversation she goes like
somebody like you I would never ever
hook up with you and I hadn't said
nothing to her and my feelings got
really [ __ ] hurt like yeah whoever
was thinking I was making progress with
the girl you know she doesn't have a
boyfriend
she always breaks my balls but if I'm
dating somebody and I was like okay you
telling me
you trying tell me I'm not gonna get
your bet you got the wrong guy and I'm
not even gonna Cosby I'm gonna do it
straight this money would be alcohol yes
I got gonna prove it to you I'm gonna
prove to you it was a challenge then I'm
gonna [ __ ] you while you're [ __ ]
strong sober it took me two years cake
but the reason it took me two years was
because I walked away from her and the
first night we we hold up after I ate a
[ __ ] in the car and the whole thing
after lobster Fra Diavolo and she broke
down on the who 18 you know she broke
down and she said that those are the
hardest years of her life well I
wouldn't call her for six months at a
time but I cut you off but got you all
like I don't even pull of any oh I hate
that [ __ ] this is what I thought when I
was that when I was at that age at that
age I had a motto I lost my mother by
the age of 22 I had an adage of my wife
and the antics
if you loved me you wouldn't do this to
me yeah and I took that friends I took
that
manage for everything you're able to
stick to and i stoled even with a woman
without a date a girl like we would date
for a few weeks and they would do
something crazy and I was out of there
because four years I stayed and I played
the [ __ ] girl oh really
yeah listen so what you give a piece of
[ __ ] to somebody else you like me
coming your eyeball nobody else gonna do
that for the price you let me do it I
think it to a hotel I got a half a gram
of coke and I come on your face and you
scooped it to come off your tits and put
it in your mouth that's priceless you
want to cheat on me cheat on me I'll
cheat on you Tina I'm saying like yeah I
had already gone through those levels
but then came the level of if you really
love me this is not when we date we fall
in love right I'm talking about
friendship
yeah if you really loved me you wouldn't
do this so there was a time period after
I was like it was really bad after I got
divorced but the first time you did
something like gone the phone stopped it
yeah God come on I'm the best at doing
it because I lost my mom and my dad so I
know how to cut people out of my life
it's weird because I can do it really
easily I would I would do it to friends
that yeah do it the people but I have to
do it like I was good like the first
person I did so was that girl huh we
after that night that she told me she
wasn't asleep of me I still remain kind
of friends of them I know my [ __ ]
feelings right yeah yeah so I was kind
of cold to her and then one night she
came up to me somewhere outside and said
some [ __ ] to me like like I I just just
I just stopped liking her for a while
that one said that to me I liked that I
didn't know that it was bothering her oh
subscribe up to me one night went off on
me and threw a cup of vodka at my face
and much what she didn't know was she
left the ice tea that she was drinking
she was drinking outside with her
friends on the floor it was cold out
iced tea was half cold and I walked up
behind and I poured the iced tea on her
head forget her shrugging her shoulders
because that iced tea was cold there was
coal
but you're gonna throw a glass about to
my face I ever say that I that's crazy
yes she was drunk so she just came up to
me and she's like what is your problem
lately and you don't talk then she drew
the [ __ ] glass a lot to me and my
woman I'm not saying it by an old woman
so I cut her off completely I cut her
off for about a year and then I had a
birthday party and she didn't make it
and the next day she called me I got an
invite her but she called like nothing
that happened we became friends and I
kept on a short leash you know if she
told me she would be somewhere I got
beaching that I wouldn't show up so at
18 I already had it I already had this
thing with this broad oh yeah I see yeah
I'll see you at that bar that you and
your girlfriends will be up to I'll see
you nothing that [ __ ] makes me crazy
twice a week oh my god she wasn't my
girl no wonder she thought she wasn't my
girlfriend she wasn't nothing she wasn't
my girlfriend she wasn't anything to me
but we always had this like little light
we would get we would go out to the same
bar alright we've got both going to
comedy store you would go talk to Dane
Cook and Joe Rogan and I would go talk
to [ __ ] you know Eliza and [ __ ]
Whitney Cummings now and then I would
talk to girls you would talk to guys and
throughout the end of the night we just
be getting closer to each other so my
two o'clock we would be back to back oh
my god what a coincidence
yeah and she would ask me to light a
cigarette and we talked and I saw you
talking to that girl Healey weren't even
dating like there was nothing on paper
we hadn't [ __ ] nothing we hadn't even
swap spit we had swap spit two years
earlier one leg but she's like that'll
never happen again
so I knew I had her so I was like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] so I stopped showing up at
different places I would tell you I'll
be down there let's stop showing up oh I
stopped showing up how dumb get [ __ ]
up with my friends and then I didn't
care at all and people come look like
what bro she was looking for you at the
bar last night not me I got this [ __ ]
and then one day out of the blue she
called me she goes so whatever you gotta
focus
[ __ ] around and what are we gonna do
this I don't know well it's up to you
but none your behavior and I might
metaphor lunch didn't kiss her
nothing sent her away I gave a coke to
holes in me and a mother found it
oh how her mother she kept it and the
mothers I got you on coke and she's like
no I'm all different friend of mine she
was cute cool as [ __ ] she was cool as
[ __ ] and I had played her like a fellow
it took me four years to after she told
me she wasn't gonna sleep with me
so what happened and then she asked me
what are we gonna [ __ ] put this [ __ ]
aside I'm gonna do this lesson in time
and then I had robbed the jewelry store
that half the mill like I spoke to her
that morning and that afternoon I told
her I was to see her that night it was a
Tuesday it was a Tuesday in like Jude
the beginning in June we had just gotten
out of high school and I'm gonna walk
home we went think hell berlo's to get a
Cuban sandwich me
ferny and two other dudes for it was
Friday's birthday three days ago and I
wished him happy birthday and he he said
thank you that's that was good enough
for me
that put a smile on my face it was June
of 82 and it was me Bernie
stinky in this kid Pelle and we went to
Gilberto's and I'll never forget saying
thumb hold on one second let me see
what's going on across Jane and Michael
they were in the car
we went think it's food and I walked
across the street didn't have a buzzer
on the door open the door walked into
the jewelry store I had a football
jersey on and that was fishnet yeah so
you could see my nipples is [ __ ] okay so
I had a football shirt on that was good
fishnet oh guess how buffed I was down
and from here it was like a regular
white t-shirt and had white numbers on
it and the rest you could see was my
stomach so the lady comes up to me and I
go she goes how can I help you clean up
I want to look at a wedding with rings I
was 18 years old oh those days I would
go in there and they would put the rings
out for me
like 30 rings yeah but I would look and
whatever one would have two rings in the
same thing I would just take one ring
and put it in my hand I would put it in
my socks I was a kid I would have shorts
on oh my god one time I want it it took
two rings and I brought him to a friend
the money he paid me for the dime was
like 300 bucks or something so here I am
I'm standing in this liquor store in
this jewelry store my buddies are in the
car like wait me go home and the lady
brings the tray of diamond rings and she
turns her back she's going I have to
talk to another customer but the place
is packed
I took the Rings put them under my shirt
all of them to go Jack oh my god
and I walked out of this jewelry store
into the car my friends like what are
you holding and I took the finger rings
on their like oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] did it you crazy Mon
God so at the curtly Lorenzo's house got
rest his soul like I'm going to West
Palm Beach this weekend and Louis
Castley those coming Saturday night and
if Lewis cast we know comes from the
show on Saturday and I have you're
listening I'm gonna pull them up on
stage and I'm gonna tell stories about
him and the other end so look I'm
getting emotional just thinking about it
because people are gonna go holy [ __ ] I
hung out with Louis from 1980 to 1984 85
I knew Louis all my life but what we
Louie did together when we had the story
about Kurt and John Crowley and how we
hung out together once a week it's gonna
kill that West Palm Beach improv like he
says he's coming for the second show the
first show on Saturday if he shows up
ladies and gentlemen and I'm gonna stop
my act I'm gonna make a great movie cast
Lido up West days I'm gonna open up with
the story about what we we me and him
may believe that we did hear sirens a
buddy of us we all took acid and we were
walking home everybody
you're pretending not to hear and they
were there because one year my friend
kept say you guys hear that [ __ ] side
and you can hear it it was loud as [ __ ]
I mean I look at Louie like what it look
like
Oh Louise like I don't get those sirens
and I'm like I don't know siren either
guys like come on you hear a siren I
can't be tripping that Harvey asked me
and Louie with each other like bro you
are tripping that horrid on the acid I
just told the story there was a puddle
on the floor there was a pothole with
like three inches of rain water yeah and
the kid looked ilysm we kept saying what
did he end up [ __ ] oh my god he bent
over these foot throw the water he just
ran away
wait wait I want to know about the
jewelry store so okay cameras this is
1983 they did have a camera because of
this incident they didn't even bother on
the door at the time it's insane
so this is June of 82 now I had robbed
them over the last two years maybe ten
times single digit things single digit
awesome bracelet a ring a [ __ ] little
[ __ ] thing and that time before I
listen to this before I robbed the
jewelry that day but when I was doing
with the wedding bands
I look over on the counter and this is
circle thing the thing that you spin
around yeah and they had gold chains in
it and on the bottom that had gold
bracelets and I remember looking at it
going that's next
oh my god I took the Rings put it under
my shirt walked out got in the car with
doors for savages I told to take me to
Chris Dee's house
the fish man and I go fish you got to
get rid of these for me and he got me I
think it was six hundred apiece from was
six thousand apiece it was a ton of
[ __ ] blue I think I cleared 12 down
something like there was something weird
I gave him a thousand for making the
deal because they couldn't be traced
back and we went on a tear and that
chick was waiting for me and at the time
we were buying coke from this dude named
mr McGrath he used to smoke Camel
cigarettes we used to call him the camel
camel breath because he would smoke
camel no filters and his moustache was
red and his fingers were red and he
would sell you the coke already in a
bottle without the spoon on it so he
would sell you the coke already in the
bottle he was the only guy sell bindles
everybody else you don't have been the
ones everybody else had a bend though he
sold you out of the little spoons so I
called that girl about six dumb I didn't
tell her what I had done she wasn't part
of that world she didn't know there were
a bunch of [ __ ] crimson Jenner and I
saw a beach at the bar at about 10:00
10:30 in fact I'm gonna go in those days
that kid Louis cast Aledo his street
name was digger and we used to hang out
at a pizza place they roam a pizza next
to it was like a business but that man
it was closed they had stairs and we did
sit there on that wall come maybe 20
years ago he thought the one up there
one that wrote digger on the wall so
we're sitting there it's a digger and
this is summer of 82 I gotta meet this
broad and I went bought 10 of those
little vials Jean my buddies sat on
Kennedy Boulevard which is like sitting
on Sunset yeah we bought our [ __ ]
case of nips which is eight six-packs
we give them to the side so the cops
wouldn't pull over and we just sat down
the steps don't blow out of the things
drinking beer and I popped a couple of
hours that blacked out then don't meet
her which drove her II know I woke up
blacked out I woke up black that I was
at home like one of Cosby's victims I
had to sit up and think about what
happened right before I remember sitting
on the stairs I started eating pills the
snorting coke I woke up I still had like
nine thousand cash and I stood out like
two coke vials like Walter right up and
she's like what happened to you last
night Jesus Christ we got [ __ ] up with
these guys issued this took all week and
then I was supposed to meet her again
Wednesday was ladies night at this bar
that we used to go to so what you did
was you gave her brought 20 bucks it was
50 Cent's drinks they buy your drinks
yeah yeah you gave them 20 years ago put
it started to happen just by me vodka
compounds so [ __ ]
crazy I'm supposed to meet her again BAM
again I went to Jersey City got a
package we went to some strip club and
it meet her again oh my I would have
murdered and how was it listen to me
guys I was brutally in love with her
like my whole day was thinking about us
having kids and getting married like I
mentioned nobody I was so heartbroken
from my mom's death and I was yearning
such a family that I actually thought I
was gonna marry her and have kids and
you know I was a [ __ ] common thief
I'd quit high school descried a great
family you know her family was going on
they all went to college they had a
family business in the [ __ ] area and
it was it was just [ __ ] crazy you
know what's crazy about that story is
the guy that we were talking about
earlier that you said we've been going
on for five years with this [ __ ]
when I first first met that guy I was so
in love with him like in love but I had
never done drugs when I met him ever
really yeah I didn't ever try cocaine
till I was like 32 or something I met
him when I was like thirty so he would
do that [ __ ] to me where like we would
go out and I was like I felt like he was
so in love with me but then half the
time he would just blow me off and not
answer not show up and no guy had ever
done that to me and it would make me
[ __ ] insane like so crazy but years
later I always assumed he was sleeping
with a whole bunch of other chicks and
that was why I'm like oh this guy's just
[ __ ] a bunch of girls later when I
learned about drugs I realized oh once
he starts partying getting [ __ ] up I'm
not gonna hear from him like they would
do blackout [ __ ] like he would send me
photos the next day of him in like a
freezer at 7-eleven like you know stupid
naked or something
so now in hindsight I'm like oh I don't
think that it was that he was [ __ ] a
bunch of people it said he was always
high that's what would happen when I
went out with my friends in those days
no matter how good-looking we were I got
to look you in the face look in the eyes
and tell you this we did not go out to
pick up [ __ ] that was the least of our
problems that's what I mean we went out
to get [ __ ]
that's how these guys we didn't want to
talk we want to nod on [ __ ] ludes we
will get our goal was to get [ __ ] up
wasted whatever you call it whacked see
back then lots of guys gonna get wet I
was never like that like even when I
party even now if I go I went to
Danville's Aryans party a couple weeks
ago which is like a huge party like
people go to get [ __ ] up I don't like
I'll party a little but like I go to
meet people and like flirt a table I
don't want the nobody that belongs down
our table we would go out to get [ __ ]
up and if a girl dead to come into our
lair we would say a couple things to her
if she wasn't on board with sick Palio a
lair and Polly would say some terrible
when the girl would just walk away
ya know he had no remorse for anything
so if a girl did come into our lair and
talk to us we would tell him right off
the bat listen where's that piece ass
you were talking about and they would
look at us like what he thought by the
way tell him to take a hike cuz I had a
buddy who was Indian and Italian very
good-looking blue-eyed brown hair
but whenever he would drink he that's
how he would pick up girls see this two
approaches to pick up women there's the
nice approach and from him I learned
that there was no nonsense approach he
would just look you straight in the face
and go Kate you're nothing going on you
gonna sit at this bar with these [ __ ]
losers really listen you gotta call
around to talk you have two bottles of
Dom Perignon let's go back to my place
I'll stick coke locked up your [ __ ] a
woman would freeze like they would just
freeze yeah like they would just lose
their inhibitions and go okay that he
was go time whatever you pay her tab
before the girl even knew what she was
doing she was in the car going to son
Nicholas too late to get out it was too
late never works on me he would talk
that and right into it
way Kate you up you at the store we know
you wasted your time
don't do a bumper this can come back I
got an Eightball assist at the house
we'll stop the task I've got a bikini
come back tomorrow for the jacuzzi here
[ __ ] his party started
and girls would just look at him like
I've never seen him would try and pull a
piece of ass at the beach a piece ass at
the beach at the beach that I could see
took her under the [ __ ] tunnel [ __ ]
her and they came back like nothing
happened
like he just met her at the beach at the
beach in front of me two minutes talked
to her that I can sit next to on the
towel next thing you know they went up
they were holding hands they went in the
water
I saw them making out Lexi you know they
went that way then they came back and on
the way home because dog I [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out under the [ __ ] bridge no
come this is a t-tubule straight I've
never been able to do that but yeah well
he was [ __ ] people straight out
that's insane
straight-up gangster and coke is that
big of a deal for some women like
they'll be like in it makes you horny
once you give me a credit card
every license on you yeah when I first
moved to Aspen in 84 this was this was
the cocaine how do you get a girl
Bassman make this noise I mean it still
works at some parties you know it makes
her coming over to your house a lot
easier Jesus like nothing happened you
don't have to ask twice
you just say that I'm sorry okay just go
listen I gotta grab a blow at the house
I love those pants on you look let's go
back and eat your [ __ ] you pay for your
tab you don't say another word because
the first person who speaks losers don't
even let it talk just pay go through the
motions and turn your back those people
follow those people follow you cuz I
don't like to have sex too high so if I
do too much I don't want to do that
gonna really tell you about the sex I'm
gonna feel it out first try to lure you
back with the coke and the quaaludes and
another broad is coming over here it's
another broad is coming over that's
either half a biscuit what the [ __ ] you
know you know what really worked on me
recently is someone magic your [ __ ]
[ __ ] magic he was wicked
together but actually that guy okay that
guy have managed to seduce me in the way
in a way that no guy ever has and it
works so well and now in hindsight I'm
like if I probably was [ __ ] and it
was like clearly game but this was his
whole thing his whole thing was I'm so
innocent I never do I've never done any
of this I never like every time you
would touch me like he touched my leg oh
I'm sorry I'm touching you I didn't even
I is that okay is that he kept asking
permission and acting awkward kind of
like how Lee is yeah but then like he
kept on like he'd get a little closer
and then he kind of cuddled me and then
before I knew it he was like it said
okay if I just feel your ass and I was
like yeah you don't have to keep asking
like you're harmless like he was making
me almost feel like god he's never done
anything like I need to like let this
guy have some fun like he seems kind of
nerdy to the point where he even said to
me you're not gonna believe I fell for
this he said he'd never felt fake boobs
this is a rock star he said I've never
felt I'd never felt fake boobs do they
feel normal and I was like do you want
to touch them like I seriously believed
every great thing about this town is
what there's only one of the town that
equals to disgust and the level of men
like this town that's Washington Oh
politicians like when me and the
stripper broke up we remained friends we
really remained friends like we there
was a bumpy parry there for a few
minutes that was awkward
and then it was funny because she showed
up at the improv she was I really missed
watching you do comedy do you mind if I
bring a date hmm
and one time her and I had got into an
argument and she pushed me and I pushed
her back and I got arrested for assault
oh [ __ ] and I never feel that she showed
up with this guy that was staring it out
to the gills and Josh wolf was standing
next to me and I look at Josh wolf when
I go she thinks I beat the [ __ ] out with
this [ __ ] Taize I saw what happened
to her I she was a really pretty girl I
met I was she was 25 and we moved here
when she was 28 her peak
and she was a sexual deviant but she
lived to be a sexual deviant you know
she would call me and tell me a [ __ ]
was Bombay and all that [ __ ] lingo
cheated which tries to be crazy you know
what does that even mean I don't forget
that she would dye your hair blonde she
would die a [ __ ] everyone put a little
streak for me with a [ __ ] uh-huh
what's her what's worse we go BAM what
do you pull lightning boy salvation
explanation point it's not a [ __ ] and
dying blondes I mean she was crazy this
is what she did she grew up in a cult
she was abused as a child this is the
result and one thing I know about her
was this is why I did get upset about
the video and I did get upset about the
nonsense with Vinny because the duration
for chicks that play in that world it's
not a good longevity it's like they say
running back as three years of this
career you can't play this game for a
long time yeah no you're right
I'm not mad at you and I'm not here to
judge you or put you down but I care
about you love you that then I was very
disappointed because the percentage of
women that this town eats up and spits
out it's amazing
that's how I do not want you to be one
me neither you don't need half of these
good dudes that you day this is we've
been friends
they're pure garbage I mean they're not
even there's not even a little bit of
classroom except for the guy that you
did that stuff to I really like it
you do yeah there's something about him
he's a respectful young man that's why I
told you don't play with him yeah you
know two things happen this last week of
things happen in life that people
understand you know I was watching the
the Cole Simpson OJ Simpson I tell you I
totally I told people listen to this
podcast every day I want you to know the
animal you're messing with before you go
to that next move before you learn that
bar or that function he's so cool he
worked at he I don't play none of that
[ __ ] yeah I want you to size up the
person you're dealing with so when they
do slice
your neck you don't sit there and go I
can't believe you sliced her neck you
know this weekend kind of McGregor got
[ __ ] up my khabib to make a mega loss
know that animal existed yeah when he
lay there at the end of that fight he
didn't know that type of animal existed
and you feel bad and it happens to you
every eight weeks that you don't know
however not that often you know two
months ago you guys houses swimming and
having a pool party and he was engaged
to another chick for eight years you
know you have to say that was a year ago
or whatever it happened you were simply
I know I know
the Agostino tell you exactly what I
think I'm getting better at it what I
try to say to using the longevity and
that [ __ ] for that woman don't those
women in this town when I went to Vegas
this last time I saw somebody who I was
dear friend to it in this town here and
she's still beautiful she's still hot
but I could see the PTSD that this town
did Tara I don't want that to happen to
you you're a great comic thank you I'm
not talking about and I don't classify
you as all you're a great woman comic no
you're a great topic and you're getting
to a precipice like like Bobby Lee like
myself like see how we're always at a
precipice you know it's time for you to
you know I know by the study piece of
ass I don't even care right now nobody
ever cares but that I was not mad at
sure nothing I was just disappointed
because where I'm coming from is that
it's like if you met me 15 years ago
you'd be disappointed with me yeah you
go Joey you're killing us a store on a
regular basis what you still doing coke
yeah
you know it took somebody on their
deathbed to tell me to call me out and
go hey man you got a stop yeah you know
and that's it you know like I said to
you
that's one Barry sure I know you eat
those [ __ ] speed pills I really don't
take those much I could though I don't
weed
how good is that I could tell when you
tweet that animal I don't take it much
I'll be to wake up in the middle of
night and see you tweeting and talking
nonsense
I always tweet all night it's just
shitty
say some nights and some nights you say
crazy [ __ ] and I could tell it usually
depends on what's going on in my in your
head personal life yeah yeah you type of
that [ __ ] I've been trying not to tweet
at night though but you know like I I
dunno what you mean and I think I think
I'm getting better but I'm also like
really really trying to work on myself
because I have a pattern with guys and
at some point you go okay it's not all
them it's your choice you're picking
these guys and even the lat even the
musician like I really thought I'd
picked a good one he turned out to be
it's just I need to pay attention to the
first red flag and like walk away and
and also though like I think I use guys
as a form of cutting I really do I think
sometimes in some ways like it's a form
of self-sabotage like when everything is
going great my life things are too good
it's like I'm not used to that so then I
need a little drama and then there's
always some dude that's like hurting my
it's it sounds crazy but I always say
like I cut with dick like I pick guys
that hurt me but I don't mean to but I
always do so I'm really trying not to
self hate and pain is a [ __ ] up thing
you know one of the things I used to do
mice do Coker's look at my face you see
the scars I would feel whereas inside my
face and I would take a tweezer and just
pick up my face until the worms inside
my face would come out that's a form of
pain you know when I did drugs I didn't
do drugs to be cool I did drugs cuz I
was really in pain and the hatred like
I've said a thousand times
I wouldn't even look at the mirror when
I was on coke I would pee and wash my
hands and avoid looking at myself self
hate self pain you know women use it by
being promiscuous women have a thousand
weapons they do some of us kulli some
new songs some of us made bad choices
for me it was lashing out at the world
and doing drugs and robbing people and
not having no like wanting to die I put
myself in situations where
I really don't care if I die don't
really want to be on this planet anyway
I just never Boston would to pull a
board date they got a more day in
starter kit I don't have the balls to
[ __ ] do it but so I'll do other
things to do mom you know life is a
weird thing and the behavior and we have
to recognize it and we don't we don't
while it's going on
we don't recognize a few years later I
mean the thing the thing that's weird
with me is like I really don't I really
like me like I feel like I like me like
I know my flaws but I also know like my
good qualities and I know I really do
people say learn to love you or
something like no I really do love
myself I just I'm I think that I'm
finally getting to a point though where
I'm happy alone and I think that's what
it is I think for so long like I needed
someone to feel a hole and now I'm
finally like like right now I'm like I
love being by myself I was never like
that like when I went up to San Jose
recently I've rented a car I went by
myself for the weekend I like drove out
to the coast and I'd like pretty much
didn't even talk to anybody other than
the shows and it was the first time I
ever did that was like happy not lonely
comfortable I've never been there you
know my mid-30s took me till now to feel
okay by myself so I think that's
changing it so like with the last guy
even though I really liked him like when
I saw you know there was gonna be awful
I cut it off and I haven't gone like
tried to go back which is different for
me I'm a half of the stripper it took me
two years to get a girlfriend not
because I couldn't get a girlfriend just
because I was so in love with comedy
that I didn't want to go through that
[ __ ] again well there's something to
that too cuz I just went out with a guy
who's a perfect catch you would love
who's amazing and was super into me but
the truth was I kept choosing work over
him every time every time and I realized
like probably part of the reason I date
the piece-of-shit guys is cuz I know in
my head it doesn't really matter
comedies first but like my career really
is first right now like that's it that's
all I really care about and then even
[ __ ] I don't I haven't even had sex
in so long you just said
two nights ago you [ __ ] dirty no I
didn't I didn't say two nights ago I
said the last guy but like it wasn't
three nights ago it was a little while
ago pretty [ __ ]
I think the last guy was the magic guys
so you know it's funny things in October
30th my special comes out yeah
I am wanting you to open not open be my
guest star in New York so we're gonna
kick off a New York Comedy Festival
Thursday November 8th two shows the
ninth and two shows on the 10th so you
have the part of this tool what I'm
doing is I want to take people who are
come on the podcast who are [ __ ] you
know starting to headline yeah who could
probably get a hundred people show on
their own and get exposed to bigger
people make the shows that much better
so I'm gonna have like George Perez and
Cleveland yeah George that's always a
[ __ ] thrill yeah I'm taking lead or a
dirty black room for me make him do 45
hey Leland ha ha ha uncle Joey's
training service that's the guy called
me and offered me the room when I go
yeah where is it somewhere Devin company
I go can I bring Liam he's like I love
Lee I go lovely do 15 I'm gonna cancel
that night I was assembly down to
Compton website that would be so fun man
to keep the check what chick I mean that
has to be a check there's no checking
I'm doing here's a black room there's a
lot of hugs and maybe a drink to get
back that's a black room jack dawg
you'll get your [ __ ] with tight tonight
[ __ ] I love it they hug you or they
crinkle up 500 singles so it was like a
50 with a drink ticket you don't know
that do you get out the car you gonna
put in the Ewing I don't want to drink
something you want in the calling you
like final hours [ __ ] you're already in
the car Compton I wonder where it is
years ago about 10 years ago I was still
doing coke and some guy called me he was
like a beep promoter around town he goes
hey man where are you tonight I got a
big room I got a big shot a night
a headliner and I go right and I made
the mistake
I thought he always paid me a hundred
bucks yeah
dad lied so he said it's a big show I
figured it'd be like 200 bucks and stuff
like that and I'm never getting the
money and putting it in my pocket and
walking up to the car and it was $60 oh
well I [ __ ] put that car in park and I
walked back and I pulled aside like a
dog
everybody here paid [ __ ] ten bucks
yeah there's 300 people in here
you better give me [ __ ] some more
money and he looked me in the face he
goes if I give you another dollar never
gonna book it again I go give me 200
more dolls never had lose my [ __ ]
number what the [ __ ] why would ya there
were people there was a ton of them that
were running game out here for a while I
thought everything was settled by a
handshake what's up dawg that was a
great set bro you're making 2,000 at the
door yeah you gotta break something off
or somebody here you go gasps yeah come
on [ __ ] nacho platter make an effort
all right if you don't want to give me
money that's fine but at least have a
case of being back here for comics yeah
it's not okay
no it's titled there's a club out here
that I that doesn't pay features that I
worked an entire weekend at and at the
end of the weekend I was like where's my
check and they're like oh we don't pay
features people want stage time and I
was like what the [ __ ] it was like six
shows or something driving back and
forth Orange County I was like no you
know I I took a look around for a while
what was going on in the young scene
from a young comic scene I got to see my
god Jason was really upset like I went
through some [ __ ] in New York New York
was rough when I was back there yes I'll
tickets yeah bring people and I thank
God I had friends that which comes to
the shows and stuff you know florins but
it's abuse it's bullying abuse that's
why I left New York the comedy scene and
then the ball to Colorado because all
the comics had their own room through
the budget hmm and they give you 20
bucks
what 20 bucks is better than anything
yeah give me ten minutes of stage time
with you at eight minutes you know but I
see how rough it is you know in these
areas this New York in the bigger
markets you go to a smaller market you
don't there's no for [ __ ] bring it
right no five hours for five [ __ ]
minutes no there's none of that [ __ ]
like San Diego you can get up I remember
when I started I would go down to San
Diego sometimes because I could do like
four shows and a night like there's so
much time down yeah used to be great
yeah there was a room down there that
the Agostino called me a few weeks ago
you should be called a comedy palace
it's still there oh yeah I just did it
with Sam Tripoli and jim Florentine
the Kenobi power yeah they still you
know the old older the old dad I booked
it yeah you stay outside with a bucket
no and do what I did at one weekend that
was kill myself wait what are you with a
bucket and collect money what are you
doing
no we didn't know I've never done that
I've done that room it was a few times I
receive thing of the world
oh no no I've got you're such a drug
junkie that I needed the money called me
up using you probably make about six or
seven hundred we break it up amongst
Atomics you're a name you've been in The
Longest Yard I said okay at the end of
the show you have to stand that side
with a buck and shake everybody's hand
they put money of them oh god you're
like Salvation Army humiliation no I
don't even like to sell merge
I don't like to peddle listen I don't
like that [ __ ] I know I'm gonna show
talking to people after what if I could
come out in between show sometimes both
shows are sold out yeah the club is like
listening you can't come on in between
shows you almost too much of a [ __ ]
nightmare up there so that's crazy but
it's always [ __ ] great to see you I
was this long I haven't seen you like
two weeks I see
I think it's been even luck I feel like
I haven't really talked to you in like a
bit of podcast in a while
oh yeah but I mean I don't think I've
seen you really and it's been a minute I
don't you know it's like the time I have
now is I love doing comedy but I like
doing five spots when I'm in town for
the week so tonight how to get back if I
could do from it if I'm home for the
week I'll do five spots to Thursday to
Tuesday and one Saturday early learn 15
and I'm back over the thing to the head
I'll shoot down there early are you
going to start yeah I got 15 and I'll
jump on Sam Tripoli's coming in Thursday
I'm off the [ __ ] for a lot of damn
West Palm Beach improv
yeah then I'm two weeks from now on how
Aries and Cleveland they're you're doing
the Cleveland Comedy Festival oh I am
November 17th but the weekend you're in
Cleveland the last weekend of October
I'm at the comic strip in Edmonton like
October 24th to 2001 is the Cleveland
comedy fest November 70 yeah oh it's at
Playhouse Square it's like the theaters
I think my shows in like the Allen
theatre it's me and Rick Glassman it's
two of us I think really yeah I think
he's from Ohio also I think it's like a
hometown well I think there's other
shows with other comics but I think ours
is just there's probably hosts or
something I think it's just the two of
us on that one we'll be fine
and then and then with you and then I
got a bunch of dates coming up yeah that
New York ami if I still believe it's
gonna be so cool Wow that people show up
a lot of people could just from the
other shows oh yeah come over just hang
on the game room yeah then it says
there'll be a lot of fun you'll get to
meet Timmy Holloway and [ __ ] I'm so
excited to meet your friends yeah I got
a [ __ ] email like I can't wait to see
Kate it's gonna be hard to focus I want
to [ __ ] her so bad like to some random
[ __ ] email god fine don't New York is
ready for [ __ ] cake we're gonna have
so much fun
although vembur a from the 10th and
particular Rudi's bob's faith was
forgetting you don't like spaghetti yeah
I can well I can't actually add the
including three positive about seafood
choices yeah there's a sale on Dragutin
for some nice Chinese know a Chinese
film which are you have the best Cuban
join the Edgewater and that's it well
and then a slice of pizza from down the
block from Gotham that's gonna be one
545 right back to LA to get here at 9:00
in the morning on Sunday morning nobody
even knows you got a loved one doesn't
even matter JetBlue like I love JetBlue
[ __ ] the best oh I wish I can
only fly JetBlue oh I'm flying the begin
this this Thursday to Fort Lauderdale
I have great at the mint like a doctor
don't give a [ __ ] about Wednesday right
no you're so lucky man JetBlue that's
like a whole bet you're getting a
king-size bed in the front that's the
best yeah you see the [ __ ] that menu
last time and I got upgraded I paid like
the extra 120 I bought a cheap seat I
got upgrade you're so fun it was that
the one when dice was on the flight with
us
no that was that was that time I got
upgraded to you always get upgraded you
know we thought I know how to play these
[ __ ] I mean I can't wait can't deal
with the [ __ ] Cuban look at the menu
of the way that Tuscan kale salad crab
avocado Rose ricotta dumplings black
garlic chicken and pork adobo if you're
a Filipino and on the way back we had
fresh fruit
acai yogurt parfait grilled and chilled
avocado plum clafoutis I didn't have
that cliff ah this looks like a [ __ ]
plum Clint buddy that shoe potato
risotto poached egg ham cheddar Amarillo
alioli and poblano [ __ ] feta cheese
you [ __ ] this is JetBlue I'm my flight I
got cheese it's this is the first thing
he showed me at the airport last night I
ate frozen chicken nuggets I didn't even
heat him up because I was lazy and
horrid frozen chicken they're not really
that frozen you can like suck on them
this is how I eat I'm so lazy I eat like
cans of tuna and frozen vegetables I
just don't care where I'm alone I'm like
I eat like the way people put gas in a
car like it's not about the food don't
what just frozen chicken nuggets in
there yeah but I mean you you sometimes
put the cheap gas you don't always put
the premium yeah but you hear your
microwave yeah but I was really hungry
and it was like 3:00 a.m. and I and I
had done a spray of the weed stuff oh my
god Joey's friend Deborah hooked me up
with this weed Wanaka THC spray that you
spray in your mouth have you tried it
yet lis I've tried other ones I don't
think I've tried that I'm gonna tell you
something by the way she shouldn't get
this late the ninth was Deborah houses
birthday so I want to wish her a big
time happy birthday happy birthday
Deborah thank you for the weed spray she
is a [ __ ] the real deal she's a great
lady he's awesome she's great on the
[ __ ] church board she was great at
the thing we saw her own women to eat
lunch and she was already having a party
we was smoking pot outside me
he was watching The Steve Simone and we
saw her and she already look cuter than
ever
she's so cool man I had a pint of
blackberry brandy she goes I'll see you
later
we Facebook back and forth and then in
the air for a couple hours and then I
went up to my room when I left on
Facebook I didn't see her afterwards I
didn't see the girl afterward she
[ __ ] Facebook me I thought I got so
hot I fall asleep passed out make it -
you shot Wow that's how cool Debra she
showed up at my show in Connecticut at
the casino and she brought me this weed
spray and I'm telling you it changed my
life like I said she gave me a tube for
you it's just in my bag and I forgot to
take it out she told me she mailed me
one too like I got six hits of acid
Philippe
I let I put them in with batteries in
case TSA pulled me over
they're little pieces of blotter acid so
it's got the acid from the battery sink
oh no oh
we're gonna do them next week I give up
I call Tia Singh he's got a bomb on a
mistake that's insane I've never done
acid I got away I got liquid acid - when
I took a little dot of it the night
before the Conor McGregor fight yes I
did and I gave sometimes I gave the tube
to the guy from jujitsu
you're crazy Joey I don't [ __ ] around I
know I'm scared of all that's why you're
so fired up then they sure that was fire
though my friends are like let's do
ayahuasca are you busy on October 15th
and I'm like they want you to do with
that I don't know they all want to go
out and some like into the woods or some
[ __ ] I'm like who plans their drug use
ahead like [ __ ] I'm not doing I'm look
I'm boring I mean I'll do a little you
know party every once in a while
drink a little I'm not doing crazy drugs
I'm terrified I'm already crazy sober I
don't need to add an acid in mushrooms
and ayahuasca I don't know what I told
the audience of Boston but I stopped
doing that opposed they booed me you
stopped to eating edibles when but I
know that once again the bull pen he ate
it though I took a half a bite of it
when in Rome you got to get down Lee I'm
proud of you you wasn't it wasn't like
an addiction thing he was I'm the type
of guy like to revolve sure I have to
catch people walk the other day I was
walking out of the house
backwoods sweatshirt huh and my wife
losers you know by the way I got that I
like it like that with it inside out
before the drive you crazy drive people
crazy
I just never say people come out hand
white shoot at all it's so funny
who cares to finish the conversation
from earlier that was the first time in
my life I learned so like I took like I
was so frustrated with my love for that
girl that I was like I'm done with this
[ __ ] like I'm walking away and I fought
it I took acid every night and cried I
was in love with her and I fought it and
when she pulled on me I was like no
you're not gonna get it and then that
went select Tuesday I was supposed to
meet her and that Wednesday I was
supposed to meet it blew her off right
the Thursday she was like I'm going out
but my blood drinking I'm hungover from
the weekend so I met her that night she
gave my coat back and I walked it to the
car like oh how about dinner tomorrow
night and we went out to dinner and then
after dinner we went to some [ __ ]
parking lot we were swapping spit and I
just started eating a monkey it was
delicious she had talked and pile around
I hate it and then after I finished we
didn't [ __ ] nothing she that's what
she broke down and she knows all those
nights she wouldn't call me would drive
me [ __ ] crazy when you wouldn't talk
to me and I learned the big part about
women in men that you can't always be
there once you pull away it drives them
crazy their insecurities come out it is
interesting because I have had a few guy
friends over the years that I'm really
close to and at some point I know they
have feelings and if I don't and I let
them know yeah sometimes they get
butthurt like or upset the way you kind
of didn't they pull away and it's hard
man because it's like you care about the
person they're your friend and you don't
want to lose them but it's also like it
and it is even weird when they start to
date someone else and you see them
giving that affection to someone else
even though you don't want it you're
like oh they're not there for me anymore
it's a weird thing but all those guys
eventually I've become friends with
again but it's never
same when they come back it's never the
same level of friendship like they're
always a little more alike but it also
teaches you a lesson it teaches your
lesson about men that you can't if you
don't give them what they want now they
don't give you what you need that's the
problem that we've had here that's the
problem that we have yeah
men do hold that against you I've been
guilty also when I was younger yeah when
I didn't know any better before the age
of 30 when you're a stupid and you're
just finding out you know there was a
time when I would just like the story
about the girl I dated and she told me
she didn't have a mother and I just
stopped talking to him right I don't
know like all that [ __ ] like I think
about that today I think oh why that I
do those things you know cause she's
young and stupid good girl I know last
week when you came in you had a
conversation that was very interesting
just enough female perspective I have a
daughter and if you look at my roster of
friends I have I am heavy friends with
women as much as I am with met yeah I
talked to maybe six women from Jersey
an occasional every other day type and
work rather than system there's one girl
that we did sleep together we remained
solid like I don't even think about that
it was just a mistake on our part we
were always better off friends you know
the the thing with this guy last week
you know that was going on listen a lot
of [ __ ] could happen when you're in high
school you know as long as I didn't put
my dick in your ass and gang rape you or
whatever I don't know if it was I don't
know much about politics I don't know if
it was a smokescreen by the Democrats or
whatever the [ __ ] I was but I'm happy
that it worked out how it did because
you can't use my behavior against me
when I was 18 against me we can't have
that happening yeah I'll make [ __ ]
mistakes when you're a kid that you
don't know about if you want to rape
somebody yeah we need to know that yeah
but you know I read something a story
one time fifteen years ago it had to be
even longer because it influenced me
turning myself in
I read about a guy that won on a date in
1950 with some chick and something
happened and they both got drunk and he
bit her a head to the neck like a
vampire was hired and she almost died
and he was Wow he was wanted for assault
in 1952 well guess what that guy stayed
off the radar for 40 [ __ ] me
something crazy I'm the timing I got
arrested in 87 yeah so it had to happen
I read the story a year before I got in
trouble he had gotten caught late in 86
but the crime was done like in 1948 or
something he had been off the grid he
had a wife children he was part of the
[ __ ] faculty at the school he was
this big-time
yeah but he got into a car accident when
they took him to the hospital he did a
background check then they fingerprinted
him and he was the guy wanted for biting
this [ __ ] woman in the neck when he
was 17 years old holy [ __ ] and it was I
don't remember what state it was in or
whatever but it was somewhere in the
Midwest because it was very small minded
yeah
but the his attorney argued that think
about it he did this but then for 40
years he'd never done anything else so
where there's smoke there's fire there's
a an eight that stings doesn't that the
thigh they couldn't figure it out the
point is he didn't continue to do it
yeah I know I made a mistake when was 17
16 18 at a party you put your dick in
some girls night when she's sleeping
she's 14 she's passed out you know we've
all [ __ ] done [ __ ]
we cannot live in a country where we are
responsible for what I do today
yesterday and the day before I can't be
responsible for something I did when I
was under 18 or 18 then he went to yeah
what kind of people go to Yale what kind
of people do this more people rich smart
and uppity yeah guys who think they can
[ __ ] you when you pass that
yeah and their dads in bayamón yeah you
know I'm saying he didn't appear that
way to me yeah it's really weird it's so
weird like I posted something about it
but it's super weird for me as a woman
especially because I feel sometimes
pressure even from my girlfriends you
know all my girlfriends like key I don't
like what you posted about saying you
don't know who's right and you should
automatically support the victims and
the thing is it's like well two things
I'm not saying that I think cabin I was
a good guy obviously but like they asked
him have you ever been blackout drunk
he has to say no because if he says I
have been blackout drunk then it's you
don't know what you did but everyone has
been blackout drunk anyone who drank in
high school or college has been blackout
drunk
and I know girls like people sometimes
victims wait to come forward like I have
a family member who's like I was
victimized as a child and I'm just now
coming forward and there's here's the
reasons and it's like traumatizing and
you're like holy [ __ ] this changes my
whole view of all these people in my
family and I understand the reason to
wait in some ways but then at the same
time it's like there's there's also
people that lie there's women that lives
women that say they're pregnant
sometimes when was the wall listen how
many people could give you an accurate
account of what happened 30 years ago
well yeah accurate you know what you
know who gives you an accurate account
of victims that lived through it a
victim remembers every is something that
sticks out in my mind yeah I think about
once a week I saw I saw a woman get beat
like a dog I saw a woman get me I didn't
see her get beat I saw the result when
she came to my house and with my mom had
a wrapper up with a towel and then I put
cigarettes the husband was putting
cigarettes out on it I mean it was just
a [ __ ] Horror Show but you remember
it I remember every trauma bit from that
night I can sit there with you go to a
psychotherapist somebody hypnotized you
put the five people in that room and
describe what I was feeling you know it
was two nights after Christmas
you know it was this joy in the air you
could smell people burning wood in their
fireplaces in Jersey you know I still
remember all those smells and I still
remember like about just being up like I
had no school like what were the chances
of me being up at 2:00 in the morning
yeah yeah I'm having little school and
all sudden hearing like like people
banging like how you let me help me out
man I'm like looking around and awesome
my mother's like opening the door she's
putting a bathrobe on and she what the
[ __ ] was that
I don't know somebody's in the door my
mother was like step back I'm gonna look
out the door she said Jesus Christ get a
knife and it was just lay there i
hunched over like in a fetal position
the key she kept saying he's gonna kill
me he's gonna kill me we had a [ __ ]
pick her up and drag her in and she was
half naked like she had a hot body I'm
gonna being like a kid going damn look
at those titties but she had blood
coming out of everyone her face was
smashed and then one got up my stepdad
got up he said what the [ __ ] is going
she's ascribes
cause the [ __ ] door and as he was
saying that we could hear the husband
walking up the block with some a knife
in his hand saying don't let da Pole da
why are you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna
[ __ ] finish you off and I'm in my dad
looking at me like looking at my mom
running upstairs and coming out with a
gun and going don't move another [ __ ]
step and we were thinking about calling
the cops but in my house we didn't call
the cops so my mother just took the lady
bandaged her up by storm I'm like like
wiping her and seeing the rag full up
with blood and that stayed with me is
that like I still want to cry I got him
a wipe and her and crying going I hope
just never happens to my mother I hope
this never happens to a woman when they
healed her up my mom and dad had to put
mature akram I'm all the cigarette burns
she must have had ten cigarette burns on
her [ __ ] chest and her back it was
just so from that lesson on it I always
learned that you gotta have
misunderstandings with a woman but you
can't raise your hands hold on no I
learned that
that night I learned that lesson at the
age of 12 or 13 whenever I was no that's
crazy
but that was the seventies and sixties
you know y'all remember Oh Jay brought
it to light in 85 before then I could
smack you in the face you could select
me with a lantern the cops come they
make me go to Louie's house for the
night yeah I mean that that's the thing
is like lately since I've been trying to
do like work on myself I've been talking
to my family and stuff and there's like
stuff that I'm finding out that I don't
remember though because sometimes you do
block out trauma you know and then I
don't know I mean the whole thing is
just it's a really weird we're living in
a really scary time in a weird time
where people can be penalized for things
they did when they were in high school
but then at the same time it's like that
is horrific and the guy that did that to
that woman like if he if 30 years later
we find out he did that it's he was
still a monster and he should be
accountable so it's just but it's also
like I've thought about that guy
many a night what happened to them do
you know she moved she waited to the
next day or something and I think my
mother went over there and got some of
her clothes and then when he was at work
she packed up and moved to the Bronx
with her sister or cousin or something
and then he I saw him for maybe another
four months and I had told her a bit my
neighborhood what I had seen like this
guy's not a good guy long he lived on
the bottom of giving on Terrace he
didn't have any kids you know I would
just see him out there working cuz
stupid [ __ ] cars all the time and
every time he seen me he gave me a look
and even looked away because he knew
what he had done that I knew what he had
done and then he moved and I never saw
him again I never I always thought about
it I always think about it especially
now that I have a daughter I have
friends you know even Ally one wouldn't
that it was on stage talking about that
she H going on the road because as a
woman you have to get the strange car
with a strange man
who drives you you don't want any of
these people there's a woman you know
it's a guy so how do you know we got in
this conversation I know no I mean it is
it's just it's it's weird I I don't
remember much from my childhood I just
your [ __ ] I hear stuff that I don't
remember all the time but the more I
hear the more to explain remember one
thing and today I went off on Lee that
went off I we were having a conversation
about working out and I told them what I
thought about psychiatry psychiatry is
very helpful sometimes yeah sometimes
she is very helpful it's helpful to go
talk to somebody there's one part of
psychiatry I do not like it that's the
picking of the scab if it's not bothered
and it's not affecting your life why
pick it up don't pick it up I agree with
that you don't remember getting molested
but your cousin did and your sister do
the cat did you know David leaving it
under there is unless like the reason
you're doing XYZ is because there's
something in your subconscious that you
don't but I don't want you to think it
up make it up oh yeah I don't want you
to think it up and now make up a
scenario that's what I want I know a
girl that I'm friends with not anymore
that introduced me to her it'll like
what comics we're coming so one time I
did a gig with her and her grandparents
of that and she was fine and the
grandparents left her money and then one
day on the drunks bushi one of the thing
that grandpa molester that she had just
remembered grandpa molested it that's
what I'm saying people remember stuff
all of a sudden I wonder that sometimes
- how what if how do you know it really
happened how do you know it's not a
story I'm not just talking about
molestation I'm just saying in general
like I hear about all kinds of violence
that happened around my family but I
don't remember ever seeing vile do you
know what I mean like how do you know
what's real I've lied to myself before
we don't know what's real and what's not
then leave that where it's supposed to
be out of your mind yeah yes let's say a
[ __ ] up story then we'll get the [ __ ]
out of here my mother used to wake me up
every day
in the morning when she got home from
the bar yeah but Chinese food a Cuban
sandwich would be healthy whatever and
she would wake me up and I would [ __ ]
hate it
some nights I liked it because the food
was good but for the most part I hate it
I just fall asleep yeah I can't wake me
up then she died I heard her yelling for
me and I turned over that was like so
for about a month I kept saying maybe
she was yelling for me while she was
having a heart attack and I could have
saved her life if I would have dug into
that foxhole I wouldn't be here with you
guys right now
yeah I'd be somebody living in a home on
the medication beating myself up being
the victims I didn't saved my mother's
life I heard her yelling in the crib you
know there's a movie called paradise it
was on about three weeks ago when I
taped it and I watched it and me and my
wife cried my wife had never watched it
it's a movie that done Jonathan Melanie
Griffith made mm-hmm right when they
remarried it might 91 John Jonathan was
[ __ ] beautiful and melody Griffin was
a piece of ass jack belly Griffin's
built kind of weird like a hips he's got
a flat ass and big hips but if this
movie Shubert
she's Kim she's cute and it's about a
couple who the kid from Harry Potter not
that [ __ ] goofy kid with the glasses
but one of those kids shows up to the
house that Don Johnson's wife as a
college girlfriend a sorority girlfriend
yeah and her husband I having problems
they have a kid so she calls to
Johnson's to see if she could drop the
kid off for three weeks that's about
this couple that had a baby and he died
and their relationship hasn't been the
same and now this kid teaches him how to
be a couple again it's a [ __ ]
beautiful Don Johnson [ __ ] hit it out
of the [ __ ] park with this book yeah
I'm a big time Don Johnson and I'm in
the town of one time but I didn't want
to Adam sell this movies yeah Nick's
wanted movies no with that bump really
bad it was me and Don Johnson in the
closet for like an hour and we would
have to walk into the room together
with our in between takes we would talk
it yeah he was great everybody say was a
dick he was great to be yeah and when I
said to my O'Brien Haysom I think your
best movies paradise hmm he thought
about it for middle egos I think so too
huh
you ever see a bump one but the point of
that thing is that the end she breaks
them then she says that she heard him
cry and she didn't turned over to pick
him up so she has to live with that the
rest of her life you know what I want
you to make a decision like I did like
what if that happened to you you have to
make a decision of what happened and
move on because it was eating away at me
and I was starting to turn into one of
those people you would do coke with
people though all of a sudden they tell
you everything about their childhood
what went wrong and you you went from
having a good time yeah suck the guys
like oh I don't want to suck it
depressed me so much yeah you know you
totally you take a girl home you got a
little bikini you something cold and
also she look she goes levitate my
father raped me when I was nine ah yeah
night is over saying yeah I'm gonna give
you aspirin I'm the question of you
ain't doing don't work out yeah that's
what that becomes in your life I think
you're right I know I'm right because it
had me for about a year you had me for
about a year thinking of that I could
have saved her life
no you could first of all when God
pretty sure number that night that night
God takes a list out of 20 names he
starts reading about and the lucky
winner is Joey Diaz you're right no
matter there you go right you crossed
the street at the haha yeah there's a
car with no right down the street and
you just get hit by a guy no here's
Vance when God wants you to go it's time
to go if he wanted me to save her he
would have [ __ ] made me save it and
also it's just living in the present
yeah this girl I'm talking about dis
killed her no until she came up one day
so I think my grandfather molested me
you think now I was just saying after
you spent this money in Mexico yeah like
now you remember after you just bought a
house and you spent this money in Mexico
now with a character you yeah but the
guy molest to you by you were spending
twenties and jumping up and down
yeah I don't need about a finger up your
ass now all of a sudden oh you think in
your church give me a [ __ ] break
yeah my friend just went to therapy and
they like dug all this oh yeah I'm like
you know I think I'm okay now you know
you know what I've never hung on if I
got a finger in the ass it belong there
I don't look bad brick I'm fine with it
and we're gonna add that comic strip
Edmonton October 24th 228 and then I'll
be with you and New York at Gotham and
then Cleveland Comedy Festival members
don't forget you bad [ __ ] I'll
see you Friday Saturday night West Palm
Beach improv we're dropping some
knowledge we got some home [ __ ]
coming over any Brancaccio is coming to
the second show we got a louis cast
olena with joey Caracappa we got [ __ ]
in phase yo man those husband's coming
we got a party so you don't want to [ __ ]
them miss I'll see you [ __ ] at
the West Palm Beach improv and now I'm
gonna Ben Cleveland also yeah two weeks
[ __ ] lay there all right thank you
very much for is I love you have a great
day yeah I want to thank Kate quickly
again for coming in always a [ __ ] fun
time with it one thing before we wrap up
first off sure watching football is fun
but it's more entertaining when you got
a little money on the game all right
guys you heard me talk about this for
weeks and somebody is still sitting on
the [ __ ] sidelines sitting there
broke like a Mamaluke whether you're an
expert or a rookie you should be betting
in my bookie why I'll tell you why I'm
the kind of guy that likes to bet a
little and win a lot but like playing
numbers on the roulette you can create a
big parlay you could pick three teams to
win if he had all three of them you
could turn a yardstick $100 into $600
there's so much to bet on playoff
baseball hockey primetime fights
college football they got everything my
bookies one bet I know you'll be happy
with all year I recommend these guys cuz
I trust them they've been around for
years and they got great online reviews
plus their mobile site is easy to use so
if you're on the sidelines and you don't
have time to mess around Christmas is
around the corner you want to make some
money you want to make a little buck a
lot my
he is the way to go login to my bookie
right now today and WD this you're like
Joey what's key this money you [ __ ] mo
any why my name use promo code Church CH
you are CH and you'll get your first
deposit matched a hundred percent that
means you put a nickel in you get a
hundred percent five hundred and you got
a thousand [ __ ] bucks and get your
party started so use promo code Church
go to my bookie you play you win you get
[ __ ] paid that's it and that's that I
also want to introduce quip to the show
quip is one of the most important things
we do for our health every day is
brushing your teeth I hope you brush
your teeth you filthy animals yet mostly
you don't do it properly quip is a
better electric toothbrush created by
dentists and designers quip was designed
to make brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and enjoyable let me explain
something
it's got sensitive sonic vibrations
gentle enough on your sensitive gums
people brush too hard and some electric
toothbrushes are too abrasive a built a
built-in ready for this one a two-minute
timer pulses every 30 seconds to remind
you when to switch sides helping you
guide a full and even clean up to 90% of
us don't brush for a full two minutes or
don't even that listen I brush like ten
minutes so my teeth are still green
I brush my teeth in the shower twice
three times a day I just keep brushing
that's why I'm gonna use whip-it the
clutters your sink or cabinet makes
traveling with electric toothbrush a lot
easier kripp doesn't require a clunky
charge it runs for three months on one
charge brush heads are automatically
delivered and a dentist recommended
schedule every three months for just
five hours that's white three out of
four of us bristles that are old
worn-out ineffective quip is one of the
first electric toothbrushes accepted by
the American Dental Association as and
has thousands of verified five-star
reviews that's exactly what you want you
don't know what brushing your teeth is
like until you use equip now do me a
favor this is why I love equipment
because they've
they're backed by over 20,000 dental
professionals the quip it starts at 25
hours if you go to get quick calm slash
Joey right now you'll get your first
refill pack for free gratis that's it
that's your first refill pack free and
get quick calm slash Joey GE t qu IP
again quip is the best electric
toothbrush created by dentists and
designers out there go to equip right
now get quick comm slash Joey and get
your first refill pack for free with a
quick electric toothbrush all right
I want to thank quick I want to thank my
bookie I want to thank Anna calm but
most importantly I want to thank you
mother [ __ ] savages because I love
you without you I'd have [ __ ] dick
thank you for listening thank you for
being part of the church family again a
shout out the cake Quigley and my main
man the [ __ ] flying Jew I love
your mother [ __ ] see you Tuesday
morning bright and early the rest he is
I see you in West Palm Beach Friday
[ __ ] night ready to smoke reefer eat
Gorilla Biscuits whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do let's do this [ __ ] kick this
[ __ ] Lee Mele kick this melee I'm
getting this knuckle thinking in my old
days